I feel ready to like whoo air it out
Joey I am ready when you are all right
so this is my first love story turning
into my self-love Discovery
um I definitely want to talk about me
coming back into this room and how when
I first walked in here I had my head up
my ass per usual I've been stuck in this
mind state of not being vulnerable not
even with other people but with myself
and it took my first relationship for me
to understand that being vulnerable and
open in the space is how you become
truer to yourself
I spent five years pouring myself into
somebody that if I spent half of that
energy going into my passions my hobbies
and my interests I would be in a world
of a difference of my lifestyle right
now I do believe that for some people it
takes being vulnerable and [__] up I
feel like I put on this Mass like I grew
up in California I grew up in Orange
County like if you know the girls from
where I'm from I'm nothing like them I
grew up really heavy I was definitely a
fat girl I did not know what self-care
meant I didn't know what self-love meant
in any kind of terms or what it meant
meant to me
and I moved to New York City ignoring
all of these like traumas in my past
thinking if I go to a different location
and I rebuild myself none of these
things will matter anymore and it took
being in a loving situation and having
to face that mirror of someone else and
myself that I realized I had been
ignoring and hiding behind a facade
trying to reach these gra or trying to
reach these concepts of what it means to
be a human and what it means to be a
woman and what it means to just walk
this Earth I put on so many different
concepts that I have to be in a career
that is respectable not so much that I
enjoy or gives me passion I felt like I
had to be in a relationship with
somebody even if he didn't love me and
he clearly showed me that he was not
interested but it didn't stop me from
trying to pursue and make a round Peg
fit in a square hole that's honestly
what it felt like for the last five
years for me I was ignoring the truest
most raw authentic version of myself
because I was scared to be someone that
I haven't seen before to live a life
that I didn't think I was worthy of I
spent more time thinking it was valuable
to hurt myself
and not Embrace what it means to love
myself instead it's been a really hard
process and I am so glad I came back
into this room to tell my story because
yesterday when I came in here I got
stuck in the nuances trying to nitpick
and be as subjective about my
experiences and removing myself
from being the center of my life again
I'm here because I want to be true I
want to start being more vulnerable and
sometimes it means taking off the mask
and not being just this character I have
real authentic feelings and concerns and
desires things that I don't always
understand but it's worth following I
have a burning passion in my stomach a
sensation that when I feel something's
right like I just go for it and love
showed me that trusting that instinct is
everything no matter if you don't feel
like it's worthy for you you trust that
no matter what I
would not be here without my first love
I would not be here without him even
with all the scars that I bear and the
scars that I put onto myself
the self-harm that I've caused myself
I'm sorry if I'm messing with the mic
but I realized that I when I first came
into this room I didn't show the true
version of me which is the girl that has
hurt so many ways myself and other
people included in this journey I've
hurt friends that I literally sit in my
room all night thinking about I [__]
that up or opportunities that I walked
away from because I didn't think I was
worthy of it even when I walked in here
the first time I was so scared of trying
to be these people I saw on the YouTube
channel I was scared to curse I was
scared to be my true self because the
Judgment that comes with it and when you
grow up being judged your your whole
life it becomes something that being
true and authentic is scary it doesn't
feel like it's real or possible anymore
and me coming back in here was
reclaiming that and pushing back and
saying would I matter and what I feel
matters and what I want to say matters
even if it touches nobody it touched me
I spent my home warning crying on the
train I missed my stop and thankfully
some other guy was definitely helping me
figure out how I was going to get here
on time and before I came in here I sat
Time Square by myself and I had the most
authentic cry because I'm here fighting
for what
I'm fighting I'm not giving up I'm not
playing small I'm doing whatever it
takes to be me and to love me even if
it's scary even it makes no sense like
when I told you I was gonna come back
even if you didn't call me everybody my
friends were like what no you're crazy
like don't go back you probably did
great I said you don't understand this
feeling
and that feeling is the reason why I
reached out in the first place again and
it is the reason why I'll keep trying
again and again and again because love
showed me that it's worth fighting for
it's worth being crazy for it's worth
looking stupid for and it's worth
finding yourself in because you matter I
matter what we want to do matters even
if it's unseen even like a tree and an
empty forest does it still make a sound
yes the [__] it does we make our noise
we make our sound we make our flavors
unique or not ubu and that's all I
really care to say because losing this
opportunity to share with people that
it's okay to be you and it's okay to be
a [__] up it's okay to make mistakes
we're not our worst mistake if anything
were our best loves we're our truest
version of ourselves even if you don't
feel it and I Inspire and be inspired to
keep pursuing that in any way no matter
what anyone says around you even if you
make no sense your connection to
yourself is the only divination you'll
feel in this earth
and that's all I Came to Say
amazing
thank you so much
so much